there's so many people in this country  that believe in taking care of one  another I know it's hard to believe  right now but there are and together we  are going to come together and take care  of one another so seeing this image is  gonna be hard for a lot of people it's  gonna bring up a lot of pain it's gonna  bring up a lot of hurt please reach out  to your loved ones please reach out to  people who are suffering in silence  right now please let them know that they  are loved and they are celebrated for  who they are  laid-off videos I was extremely shocked  and disappointed when I learned of  Justin Trudeau's actions this evening  wearing brown face is an act of open  mockery and racism it was just as racist  in 2001 as it is in 2000  what Canadians saw this evening is  someone with a complete lack of judgment  and integrity and someone who's not fit